AS WE GO TO
OUR NEXT GAME, HORROR SCOPES.
HORROR SCOPES.
OVER HALF OF AMERICANS BELIEVE
IN ASTROLOGY, AND TWO-THIRDS OF
AMERICA BELIEVE STEPHEN HAWKING
IS THE WORLD'S BEST ASTROLOGER.
UH, HOROSCOPES USUALLY OFFER
VAGUE PREDICTIONS LIKE, "YOU
WILL FIND SUCCESS IN A NEW
CAREER" OR "APPLE WILL AT SOME
POINT RELEASE A NEW IPHONE."
SURELY, EVEN ASTROLOGERS SCREW
UP SOMETIMES, SO, COMEDIANS, I
WOULD LIKE YOU TO GIVE ME AS
MANY BAD HOROSCOPES AS YOU CAN
IN 60 SECONDS.
AND BEGIN.
(BELL DINGS)
NATALIE.
>> CANCER, YOU HAVE IT.
>> HARDWICK: OH, NO!
THANKS, THE STARS. POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
RANDY.
>> VIRGO, YOU WILL APPEAR ON THE
SHOW @MIDNIGHT AT YOUR FATTEST.
>> HARDWICK: ALL RIGHT. POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
PAUL F. TOMPKINS.
>> LIBRA, WHEN ONE DOOR CLOSES,
IT'S THE DOOR TO THE GAS
CHAMBER.
YOU SHOULDN'T HAVE KILLED THAT
GUY.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS. POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
RANDY.
>> ARIES, HOLLOW OUT A LOAF OF
FRENCH BREAD TO HIDE YOUR DILDOS
IN.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
PAUL F. TOMPKINS.
>> GEMINI, TODAY YOU'LL
UNDERSTAND WHY YOU'RE THE SIGN
OF THE TWIN.
THEY FOUND A LITTLE SKULL IN
YOUR ABDOMEN.
>> HARDWICK: YES, POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
UH, PAUL F.
>> SAGITTARIUS, DID YOU WAKE UP
IN A HOTEL BATHTUB FILLED WITH
ICE?
YOU SHOULD HAVE READ MY COLUMN
YESTERDAY.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
NATALIE.
>> YEAR OF THE RAT, UH, YOUR
FRIEND IS THE YEAR OF THE
DRAGON.
TRY TO PRETEND YOU DON'T FEEL
UNCOOL ABOUT THIS.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
RANDY.
>> [BLEEP] LIKE NOBODY'S
WATCHING.
>> HARDWICK: ALL RIGHT.
POINTS.